[Music]
foreign
s bigger than Valerian and Vega back in
the days of the Valyrian Freehold and
also were their dragons that still
survive in the Doom of valyria but
didn't come out to the outside world so
let's dig deep into this and discuss
these topics in detail
so firstly let's start with discussing
the size of valerion and then we can
jump into the main content Valerian was
the largest of all the Targaryen dragons
since aegon's Conquest his wingspan was
so large that his shadow could engulf
entire towns when he passed overhead his
Jaws were large enough to swallow an
oracle or even a mammoth judging by the
size of the skull at the red keep and
him being a bit larger than Vega who we
have assessed to be around 240 to 250
feet long we can say that Valerian was
around 300 feet or 90 meters long with a
wingspan of 500 to 600 feet or 150 to
180 meters across
so Valerian was the only family Dragon
still alive at a time of the conquest
who was born before the doom and his
birth in a more magical place and time
may have contributed to his size even he
had limitations having spent the
majority of his life in a post-doom
environment with no magical intervention
if valyrians use Fire magic to
manipulate Dragon size and growth rate
then the pre-doom era would have
produced larger dragons than the
post-doom era where there was no magic
ambient or ritual based to increase the
dragon size and of course before the
Doom valyria hosted a large number of
dragons including famously in the second
spice War when some 300 dragons came
into battle so it is highly likely that
there were dragons the same size and
even bigger than Valerian during that
time
while the black dread was not fully
grown when the targaryens lived in
valyria he did grow to his maximum size
later on in life in Westeros we also
know that the targaryens were only of
middle status there just one of 40
dragon lord families so assuming that
the number and size of the family's
dragons had any Berry on their standing
it stands to reason that other families
in valyria maybe had larger dragons than
Valerian at its peak are quite a few
valerian-sized dragons so it's that's
the reason again that if the targaryens
had or used to have dragons of huge size
then their status would be of high Lords
but since they were only middle families
then even dragons of the size of
valerion would be average
there is also another factor to consider
here Valerian spent his later years in
King's Landings Dragon pit so if the
dragon pit truly limited dragon growth
in comparison to what it would have been
if they were allowed to live more freely
then valerian's growth rate in later
life would have been stunted whereas a
comparable Dragon living in Valeria
would not have been so restricted and
would have grown bigger and bigger with
the ambient magic that is present in the
place even the cannibal that was in
Dragonstone lived longer than valerion
and would maybe be as big or bigger but
since there were never any mentions
about his size this is still just a
theory of all the Targaryen dragons that
we know valerion was the only one who
was hatched before the targaryens left
valyria and he lived to be around 200
years old the other two dragons from the
conquest vegar and miraxis were not
nearly as big as Valerian at that time
but by the time of the dance of the
Dragons Vega was approaching the size of
the black dread but the strange thing is
that the dragons that were born in
Westeros always became smaller in size
every successive generation until blood
magic was performed again to give birth
to dany's dragons drogon rhaegal and
viserion which would have grown to quite
an astounding size given their fast
growth rate but were killed at a young
age but drogon is still alive and might
still be growing growing to be as big as
the black dread given his fast growth
rate
so the point is this imagine the
Valerian dragons at the peak of their
magic since Valerian was from valyria he
became the largest known Dragon Vega
which was born around 52 BC in
Dragonstone still had a lot of magic in
her jeans and so she grew to almost the
same size as valerion then the second
generation dragons like vermouth dream
fire and Silverwing were smaller than
Vega then we have the third generation
which were characters and melees and
they were of middle size the fourth
generation dragons like Cyrax were even
smaller this went on and on to the loss
of the Targaryen dragons grew to be the
size of a small doll
yet there is another story of valerian
flying off to valyria with area
Targaryen one of his writers what was
told is that the Doom kill of all the
Valerian dragons other than the
targaryens but there is a possibility
that there are other dragons who
survived without anyone knowing some of
which might have been elsewhere then
returned to valyria on Instinct just as
Valerian apparently did and lived there
without anyone on the outside world
knowing since Valerian was the biggest
known Dragon at that time and something
wounded him to the point of him not
returning to valyria again then there
might be something in valyria that was
bigger and badder than a black dread
maybe a larger Mina Valyrian Dragon had
survived the doom and gone back to
valyria and had met and fought Valerian
there but that doesn't explain what
happened to Aria which kind of looked
like radiation burns the Doom was some
sort of magical experiment that went
horribly wrong and in that case the
valyrians were probably in the middle of
something and whatever they were doing
were causing the Doom to hit it and
those monstrous things that were the
result might have caused the Doom anyway
the conclusion is this that there must
have been dragons bigger than Valeria in
the past owned by more powerful Valyrian
Dragon Lords but as to whether there
were still dragons in Valeria that is
highly doubtful in the least
so that's what we have on this topic I
hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos right here on this channel till
the next one take care fam